let me show you how I would do it here
see this there but I want to prove okay
I wanna have a look at that left-hand
side let's have a look at the left-hand
side and let's play with it I want to
try and interact with it in such a way
so that I could simplify simplify work
through it use this piece of information
which I've assumed to be true and then
see if I can get it in this form okay so
let's have a go this is 7 to the power
of k plus 1 minus 4 to the k plus 1 plus
2 is 3 okay so that's the left hand side
of the statement I want to work with
okay now I want to use this fact this
fact here right because I've assumed
that it's true I don't actually know
it's true but I'm just just seeing what
happens if it is okay so in order to use
that fast I need to manipulate this so
it looks more like this okay now as an
example look at the first term 7 to the
k plus 1 what's the difference between 7
to the k plus 1 and 7 to the case what's
the difference between these two terms
it's a it's just the plus 1 right what
but it's in the index so what does that
mean yes you should very good it's
multiplied by 7 the difference between 7
squared + 7 cubed is that this is seven
times bigger do you agree and you know
seven 2007-2013 this number is seven
times bigger just that makes sense so I
can rewrite this guy as 7 times 7 to the
K does that make sense why is this
helpful because it looks a little more
like this so I'm going to get closer to
being able to use this now what about
this guy
sir this guy is related to that one over
there as well right
what is the difference cuba me I don't
Teresa well what's the difference
between this and this term difference
it's four times bigger just like this
guy was seven times bigger this one has
an extra multiple of four right so
therefore I can write this as takeaway
for lots of
for to the cave plus two okay so this is
good this is progress because it looks
closer to this but it's not quite there
not quite there you could see for
instance if I had say five lots of this
and five lots of this right I could take
out a common factor yet so I would have
five lots of this now if that were true
what would be really nice is I know that
number is divisible by three
can you see why think about it this
number that I've written on the bottom
I know it's divisible by 3 because it's
five times a number I've assumed is
divisible by three well if you've got
some number like say say this if you
multiplied by five it'll still be
divisible by three if you want divided
by 18 still we do this by three does
that make sense because I'm once you've
already got that divisibility property
you can multiply by any integer you like
okay now I don't have fives here is here
I don't have the same number I've got a
seven I've got to take away four okay so
I'm going to again use a bit a little
bit imagination and see how I can fiddle
with this I want the same number in both
instances I want the same number you
know seven here you have four here but
seven has four baked into it isn't it
right seven is just I'm going to eat
more figures seven is just our shorthand
for one plus one plus one plus one plus
one plus one plus one and that's a pain
to say so we just say 7 right but can
you see that 3 is hiding in here where's
three if you just take these guys and
put them off to the side he is three
right so 3 is inside seven if I just
tease it apart a little bit it's very
obvious right watch how many - say was
left over if I take away three of them I
said forward in them because that's four
if I take away three of them
what's left behind there are four do you
agree
like this is just I've just broken it
apart let me highlight it for you this
guy I've just chopped it into two pieces
okay but this is an improvement can you
see why because look now I have this
situation which is just like what I have
over here I can factorize three lots of
this that's that's three that's
important plus for lots of this have
almost there
are the gears turning for you yet have a
look at what's going on here right see
this number here what do I know about it
what have I assumed about this number
I've issued this numbers to visit by
three right so therefore this whole
thing where you multiply by four it's
still divisible by three do you agree so
he says what about this guy what do you
know about this guy it has to also be
divisible by three because look it's
three times three cares what this is is
three times something that's a whole
number okay so I'm going to make this a
little obvious by substituting you what
I assumed to be true okay so this is for
lots of three pay by assumption this
phrase here that I'm just writing on
this side here is a really important
phrase if you want to be really fancy
and sound you know technical and
impressive you could say by the
inductive hypothesis which is a fancy
way of saying hey this is the thing I
assumed to be true right it's inductive
because part of a proof by mathematical
induction it's a hypothesis because what
is a hypothesis yeah it's an idea and
you're like I'm not sure it'll work but
let's just try it on and see what
happens okay so now I can factorize out
one more time because everything is a
multiple of three do you agree that's
this 7 to the k plus 4p
this is what I was after right because
see this guy it's got to be a whole
number right it's made up of all these
hold of the pieces so this is three Q
where Q equals this guy are you happy
so what have I achieved let's stand back
and look at the entire thing in a good
space so what our chief is I know if
there's some value where these things
works right then you can show that it
works for the next value that makes
sense I don't know what to tell you it's
remember I just assumed it I don't
actually know that it's true but if
there's some value suppose it's true for
K being 100 that means I can use that
fact to prove for 101 but if it's true
for 101 that means it's true for 102 as
well if it's true 402 that means you can
use that back to prove for 103 and so on
forever like does that make sense so if
it's true somewhere anywhere it will be
true for all the subsequent numbers
because that's what this proof shows us
okay but hold on hold on I actually know
I proved properly that it's true for the
first value you see that that was a very
first thing that we did right so if it's
true for this first value then this is
true for K equals 1 which means it's
true for K equals 2 but if it's true for
2 then I can use that to prove it true
for 3 if true for 3 then for four and
five for every positive integer does
that make sense now everything I just
said um when I was in school and I had
to do this topic I had to basically give
you that that maybe 40 50 words I just
said you have to include that as a
little paragraph underneath all this
writing and then we were like as HSC
Marcus we thought that's really bad
we're just making people write the same
thing over there it's very long so all
you guys have to do is say therefore
proven by the principle of mathematical
induction you might feel like oh that's
a lot of words well we used to quickly
recall the paragraph that you had to
write over this we used to call it the
essay right and you have to memorize all
the subsidence you have to produce the
whole thing and really what we're trying
to understand and get you to demonstrate
is all this stuff
not that paragraph at the end so that's
why all you have to do is write that
phrase okay